taika ytt store ragnarok wasn't just a
fresh and exciting new direction for the
chris hemsworth starring franchise
it was also a shot in the arm for the
marvel cinematic universe
as a whole ever since their introduction
to waititi's colorful
and fun take on the norse god of thunder
fans of the film have been eagerly
awaiting a follow-up
thankfully one is on the horizon we
already know a few things about the
upcoming thor love and thunder
one of the most crucial being that it
will feature the return of natalie
portman as scientist jane foster
she was also thor's love interest in the
first two films
until she dumped him she didn't dump me
you know
i dumped her some mutual dumping but
wait there's more news
not only is portman returning she'll be
picking up the hammer and becoming a
goddess of thunder
herself this has prompted massive
speculation about what that means for
hemsworth's future
with the franchise he's slated to appear
in love and thunder
but will jane's ascension to superhero
status meaning it's the last we see of
hemsworth as thor
for the first time in a thousand years i
i have no path
i do have a ride though move it or lose
it hairbag
during an interview with poland's l man
which has been translated from polish
hemsworth addressed the question head on
when asked if love and thunder would be
his last outing as thor
the actor replied that he's not planning
on retiring from the role
plus the character of thor is too young
for that he's only 1500 years old
hemsworth also added that he hopes he
doesn't have to say goodbye to the
franchise
so it sounds like if hemsworth has his
way the next thor movie won't be his
last dance this is great news for fans
of one of marvel studios earliest
avengers
in the same interview the australian
actor also teased fans about what to
expect from the film
we've already heard from waititi himself
that love and thunder is allegedly going
to put ragnarok to shame
in the wild and crazy arena guys we're
coming up on the devil's anus
based on what hemsworth had to say in
his lman interview it sounds like he's
in agreement with waititi he explained
that after reading the script
he's very excited about the film
according to cinema blend the movie was
originally set to complete filming in
2020
but production has been pushed back to
early 2021
that means a longer wait for thor fans
but hemsworth reiterated that the delay
will be worth it
while he didn't reveal anything specific
about the movie's plot
he did say he had even more fun reading
this script than he did reading the one
for thor ragnarok
and that's saying a lot because
hemsworth referred to ragnarok as
brilliant
if you're mostly a fan of marvel movies
and haven't explored the comics
you may be wondering how exactly jane
foster becomes thor
does that mean she's replacing the
previous store the plotline of why tt's
film appears to be drawing its
inspiration
from a comic story that unfolded across
the original sin crossover series
and thor beginning in 2014. in this arc
thor odin's son becomes unworthy of
wielding meownia
which is engraved with the phrase
whosoever holds his hammer if he be
worthy
shall possess the power of thor with
odin's son out of contention the next
most worthy candidate steps up
jane foster she picks up the hammer and
becomes a goddess of thunder
jane foster's reign of sora in the
comics sees her waging righteous battle
against the forces of evil even though
she is also undergoing treatments for
cancer
we won't spoil the whole thing but
suffice to say heavy is the hand that
wields the hammer we still don't know
how closely ytt's movie will adhere to
the story of the comics
but hearing a hype thames worth seems
for love and thunder we're guessing
he'll still have a substantial role in
the film
and considering that mjolnir has changed
hands in the past there's always a
possibility that he'll eventually
reassume his godly duties
and be reunited with his hammer
especially since he has such a deep
physical and
emotional connection to that sacred
weapon sounds like he had a pretty
special and intimate relationship with
this hammer and that losing it was
almost comparable to
losing a loved one it's a nice way of
putting it
as of now fans will have to wait until
february 11
2022 to find out exactly what kind of
madness ytt
has cooked up for them with thor love
and thunder any appearances in the
franchise for hemsworth after this movie
remain to be determined however it's
good to know he's keeping the heimdall's
gate
open check out one of our newest videos
right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite marvel movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]